in this capsule we will be reducing the
notion of probabilistic reasoning in
artificial intelligence then the
objectives of this capsule if those who
will follow
it's going to be basically coming back
on basic concepts in theory of
probabilities to know the notion
random variable event
marginal joint probity
conditional the rule of chaining the
basic rule is the notion
of independence possibly
conditional between the variables
random
you really saw most of these
water concepts and so we want to read see
there to make a fast since we're going
need these lot notions in the
capsules that will follow in the rest
of the body then the idea behind the
pro reasoning to ulysses is actually
develop agents like youtube is
agent in a context of a
environment that relate
deterministic therefore an environment that there
will be possibly stochastic what that
in practice means that I am
maybe in an environment where my
actions can have effects that
are not determined what are
uncertain I could so are
necessarily it will involve
genres some uncertainty by
relation to what state I am in or
what is the state of the environment
maybe my interaction with
the environment even makes that
the observation acquisition during my
old environment but my sensors
is going to vote for gross so is kind a little
uncertainty about what is
the exact measure of the information that
I acquired via my environment
so that's some features on
observe when one is in a
stochastic environment with
probabilistic reasoning we are in
able to reason and incorporate
this uncertainty link it to the stga
stochastic city of my environment
in the reasoning of my agent here
a very small example of what we want
say by uncertainties imagine that I have
different holding shares which
corresponds to taking action
to go to the airport
you are minutes before the departure of my flight
is there the question is above all a
action was given for a value of
your data is what this action is going
allow me to arrive in time for my
flying in practice in the real world on
can identify several problems that
are all problems basically
related to uncertainty an uncertainty by
relation to my environment
so I could have an observable it
and partial of my environment so
for example before leaving I connect
not exactly what are the
road conditions what traffic
no goethe institute can have some
uncertainties related to the fact that my 100
on its edge and so is it if I get
information in relation to traffic via
announcements of traffic to the radio there are
a certain delay between when is that
we observe the traffic there is when is
what the traffic will be announced to the
radio
so that's the noise equivalent
that is, a defect in
the information that I get via but
without a vagueness if you want
also we see uncertainty in
the facts of my actions so even though
I really intend to
make no accident or problem
the airport ben maybe I'm going
have a puncture or go
maybe have breakdowns help us out
so in this case it's not something
thing that I control perfectly
lauriad few certainties to know what
that well and truly succeed a bit even
if there is no traffic and generally speaking
I have certainties him to the fact that the
complexity of my environment that
involves my car but 1 6l full
other users of the road network is
so big that it's getting
too difficult to model all this is to
because of this kind of uncertainty
precisely on comment what my
environment that are the properties of
my environment
and so it's convoy uncertainty
incorporated into our model directly
but we will have to manipulate and
problem with a reasoning that is
purely logical and deterministic by
example with the logic of first
roles is that either I'm going to do some
arrived a system that makes people
draws conclusions that are and ronning
so kind of 25 allows me to me
allows with 100% of to enjoy with me
guaranteed to arrive on time so it was
produces something that I can not
really guarantee as far as he
could be an accident so much
serious that the road network would be
totally congested for a lot
longer or game could actually
to be unable to draw anything other than
conclusions that are made little
exploitable this view of taking
of decision for my agent so I
could perhaps draw a conclusion
of the kind at 25 allows me to get to
time but only if it does not rain if a
no accident is educated so or
auger number full conditions which that
I'm actually not able to
check exactly where I can
with a conclusion of the kind ben at 1440
allows me to arrive with big big
this certainty of arriving in time for
my flight but in what if it is little
exploitable in the network this is a
decision that is so conservative
that it forces me to for example pass the
night at the airport even though I could have
take a little bit of luck is
arrived at the airport with a priority
still high enough so this
that we will use instead as a tool
to reason in a
context we note the uncertainty or so
in a context where we have a
stochastic environment too much is going
to be the probability theory we're going
use that as a tool to take our
decisions
that will allow us to model the
likelihood of the different events
in my environment
and that's going to require among other things that
I formulate
beliefs for my relative agent
to the environment then also that I
formulates hypotheses about what is the
likelihood of some observations
so observations that corresponds to
events that would take place in
my environment and the theory of
problem will give me a theoretical framework
which will allow me to put
up to date what is my estimate of the
likelihood of certain events
for example political is well and truly
traffic or downright politics
the conclusion that is barely
know what I will succeed in arriving
in time so the theory of politics is going
give me the theoretical framework will me
allow to do this type of
reasoning where I'm going to be able
observe some observations then
update my estimate of the
likelihood of different events
in my environment
so that will allow me too much in my
example of saying ben after watching
that no traffic
what becomes the probability that at 25
allow me to arrive on time and so
will also see more really
facilitated the modeling of my
environment
since we will be able to take some
phenomena that are too complex for
be well described in a formal way
and then convert them into something
that we will generally call the
noise ie a certain
inaccuracy in relation to measurement
exact of something in my
environment
so the probabilistic modeling is going to me
to do is to simplify
of much the modeling of
the environment by taking what is
complex and modeling as being a
simple noise